now that we have this foundation we've
read all the letters of our own
instruction book we can start building
on that particularly in ways that
benefit medicine we can use it in ways
that also help us understand how life
works is a basic science kind of
question but for me as a physician the
part I'm most excited about is how we
could use this to prevent to diagnose
and to treat disease and those things
are happening rather quickly building on
that foundation of this instruction book
sequence that we finally have so we are
able now to be able to look at that as a
reference and then look at variations in
the genome that point 1 percent of the
DNA where people are different and find
where in that are the glitches that
predispose people to diabetes or heart
disease or cancer and that gives us then
a golden opportunity to be able to do
better prevention and also to develop
new treatments because we have a real
light shining on causation that we
didn't have before so ultimately over
the course of 10 or 15 years this is
going to revolutionize the practice of
medicine I do think when people look
back in a few hundred years and ask what
were the exciting things that happened
about this time in history the human
genome project will rank very high it's
probably the most significant organized
scientific adventure that humankind has
ever been on and it's looking like it's
turning out pretty well